hi I'm Thomas Middleditch emotional
Jackson jr. and this is the wire
auto-delete
interview Jackson jr. married this is a
bit of a class ring but no I'm not
married
I am married to my playstation is a
Jackson jr. single no I'm not single I
have a girlfriend Danielle and the love
of my life is my two-year-old daughter
Jordan hi lad daddy is the say Jackson
jr. related to Ice Cube no he's my dad
for like my whole life
there's O'Shea Jackson jr. related to 50
cent now this is a common
misunderstanding cuz his last name is
Jackson and he's black that we are
related somehow but no I just call 50
cent uncle Curtis to play off the
Jackson thing and he's crazy he knows
that I think he's crazy he sent me an
e-mail like raving about you is Thomas
Middleditch vegan let's call let's call
it aspiring its Thomas Middleditch
married yeah I put a ring on it it's
Thomas Middleditch it's Thomas
Middleditch who he says he is it's
Thomas Middleditch Jewish you know I get
this a lot really from up from some
Jewish people they're like oh you're
Jewish why why would you say that and
then I have to make them be anti-semitic
well I'm not though
what does Godzilla roar sound like kind
of like scraping a like when you pull a
chair and desk in a loud audio it like
ends with the mmm like it has but it
sounds like you're dragging a
desk and chair it's got a bit of the
Bram the Hollywood yeah you gotta have
some bass in there and like a little bit
of like Paul Lynde pollens laughs you
know the Center Hollywood Square old
guys are watching this right
why does Godzilla attack cities he
doesn't attack cities he attacks
monsters and the cities just happened to
be around him
Superman attacks enemies and the
buildings are just in the way and they
fall down you don't say Superman attack
cities all right collateral starring the
two guys that are in collateral things
Godzilla would say by Thomas Middleditch
oh did I do that
Family Matters he would also throw in it
does anyone have any cheese he's like a
really big fan of Family Matters and
then he'd say deal with it and like gift
shades why is Godzilla the king of
monster ESL well Godzilla's the king of
monsters because he is the Godfather of
all these giant creature movies you know
there's references to Godzilla all
throughout pop culture for my rubber has
fans Reptar is Godzilla spoiler alert so
there's you know this he's just the
biggest and baddest and nobody can mess
with him and to quote Godzilla King Kong
ain't got on me real talk is godzilla
kaiju yes we did wait wait ooh that'd be
the last question fight these guys look
odd you should've been the first thing
on there but yes he is how much detail
cannot go into that alright alright yeah
passion passion Godzilla yeah a I movie
Thomas Middleditch oh I believe they're
talking about Sun Spring which was a
movie written entirely by an AI program
it was given a couple like a prompt like
a thing to write about and then a bunch
of science fiction material to write in
the style of science fiction and it is
crazy yeah yeah it's a short film we
tried to like execute it as if the
script was like
now I like Academy award-winning script
it's so like we did it for Batum we
tried to execute the vision and it is
it's cookie the dialogue is like
autocomplete mmm it's such a fever dream
it's getting better
Thomas Middleditch and Ben Schwartz
correct correct
he is a Jew now I and I do a two-person
improv show we're touring the nation we
just did Carnegie Hall sold-out Chicago
theater sold-out out here ballin yeah
yeah expect it
Thomas Monroe - wolf on Wall Street
kinda was such an opportunity to work
with Martin Scorsese little mercy don't
squeak do it again
try something new he goes away how's it
I mean yes yeah I shook Leonardo
DiCaprio sayin he's a big ice cube man
the man gets it done really yeah cool
maybe like the three of us like we only
know I mean I can make it happen
all right Thomas Middleditch McDonald's
with a friend I made us a little rap
because it was the day when McDonald
said sort of first come out with that
like about that and like oh it felt very
Justin Timberlake is it not yeah and it
felt like oh like kids like playing
basketball yeah yeah I love my dogs
tunas so felt so like pantry to like
check it out Youth urban culture check
it out and I actually made a little
short making fun of it and I put him
online it became viral and then
McDonald's bought it they bought it Wow
yeah they bought a parody uh Thomas my
mother's dog you forgot the yes I got
two baby meatloaf the min pin and Potter
the street month and they're both real
sweeties what is Jackson jr.
snapchat well Shay Jackson's doing your
snapchat doesn't exist just yet but
O'Shea Jackson jr. z-- snapchat also
doesn't exist I don't do snapchat I
think snapchat is ridiculous
there's no reason why I should send
anybody videos of me as some sort of dog
or fire truck or have a
crown halo flowers it's just weird this
is not for me they got a couple of silly
filters set up and unused ago it's
pretty steep what movies does O'Shea
Jackson jr. play in Straight Outta
Compton
angry goes West dinner thieves longshot
Godzilla king of the monsters I'm also
in just mercy and me and your mother
have a lovely movie what was O'Shea
Jackson jr. in the military oh no
definitely wasn't I appreciate everybody
who makes that sacrifice to join the
military and to make sure that I'm able
to do the things that I love to do in my
life everybody who takes that sacrifice
and signs up should be treated like a
hero when they return home was I'll Shay
Jackson jr. a Marine redundant at that
point no I know see the previous
question where does Thomas Middleditch
get his grief
where does time some of us live here in
beautiful Southern California in an
address that's none of your goddamn
business
that's fair trust me it's gated no it's
not where is Thomas Middleditch heading
with this career Oh from Canada British
Columbia Canada
okay Jane Thomas Middleditch read and
write oh program contentos program look
if you need a basic website yeah I can
handle a little HTML as long as you know
I'm able to look at some tutorials what
is Thomas Middleditch thinking what is
Thomas Middleditch twitch handle it was
at Middleditch but I'm not sure if it's
not sure swishes for me it's a bit weird
playing video games than them you like
thanks for the 10 bucks teenager like
they're giving you money
feels weird you're a bad man does O'Shea
Jackson jr. sing in Straight Outta
Compton I'm not a singer I do rap and
down so no definitely not singing
singing is anytime they different scenes
for me Oh
so I doesn't matter yeah does okay
Jackson jr. you have any tattoos I do
not I don't even have my ears pierced I
feel like when God sees me he's gonna be
like that's him and you know he's gonna
bring me right in sometimes we have too
many tattoos just says like I can only
have one type of job in nothing else rap
I used to when I was younger I ghost
right here and there but it's I
definitely want to be known for my
acting because I figured that nobody
wants to see Superman throw
hundred-dollar bills at a girl it's just
weird
it just makes it awkward I just don't
think Disney would like me know and they
typecast rappers it's just how it is
it's unfair to play a rapper some sort
of music producer exactly it's a very
powerful music asking what movies was I
in is a good way to start my career it
makes me know that y'all care when you
see me in the streets
holla at you man and no applause just in
money